لقد كنت تشرب الخمر الليلة، لقد
حصلت للتو على رحلة
كنت تشربها الليلة يا سيدي، أنا
نقيب، أنا متقدم في
قسم شرطة أوكلاهوما سيتي،
أي قسم تحقيقات
[موسيقى]
هاه،
لن أطفئ الكاميرا، حسنًا
سأخرج من السيارة،
لا بد أنك تمزح معي
[تصفيق]
ربما تبدأ،
لا أستطيع يا سيدي، من فضلك، أعلم أنك على علم
بسياسة كاميرا الجسم لدينا، وتعلم أنه لا يمكنني
إيقاف هذا المكان مرة أخرى ولكني
أرغب في ذلك  للتحدث معك
لا أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك يا سيدي من فضلك من فضلك
أحب التحدث معك هل
ستجري الاختبار أم لا
قبل ذلك من فضلك تحدث معي سأتحدث
معك بمجرد أن تتمكن من إيقاف تشغيله يمكنك
تشغيله  يمكنني إيقاف تشغيله بمجرد
الانتهاء من تحقيقاتي حسنًا،
أنا أسألك
أنا كابستون أفهم ذلك سيدي وأنا
رقيب على هذا ضابط الشرطة
اسحب الجدار ولا أظهر محاباة لأي
شخص بغض النظر عني  لا تهتم إذا كنت عضو
عصابة أو رئيس
الولايات المتحدة يا سيدي، أنا لا أطلب
ذلك واحد
اثنان ثلاثة أربعة خمسة ستة سبعة ثمانية تسعة
غلين يستدير لي، ضع إجابتك
على ظهرك، هل ستعتقل  أنا يا سيدي
نعم أنا
نعم، سنقوم بإيقاف تشغيل الكاميرا الآن